buckle up the Democratic mob is out of
control grasping at straws it is
officially a psychotic state of denial
this is the absolute truth and reality
that the Democrats in Washington the
media mob cannot possibly come to grips
with the reality to the truth that will
set them free they are now in a
psychotic rage and it keeps spinning
over and over again in their little
liberal brains every single thing I'll
say it tonight once and for all you hear
from this day forward about Muller and
Russia and collusion and obstruction and
Trump is nothing but forever meaningless
and just a lot of noise by bitter people
four separate investigations concluded
no Trump campaign Trump Russia collusion
none zero nothing nothing they say is
going to change that the FBI's
nine-month counter-intel investigation
nothing the house intel investigation
nothing the bipartisan Senate
investigation nothing and Special
Counsel Robert Muller's witch-hunt found
nothing and they were trying Muller is
done it's over this is like worse for
them then election night 2016 especially
when the exit polls showed at 5:15 that
Donald Trump didn't win a single state
this is like it showed in 2004 John
Kerry was the next president wrong again
look at the liberal tears panic mayhem
and downright unhinged nature of
everybody tonight continue the hysteria
and frankly let me be blunt here this is
now officially a mass mental disturbance
never before seen on this kind of level
full-blown psychotic meltdown the rage
Trump mobs new favorite target it is of
course they got to blame somebody but
themselves for the lies they told and
the conspiracies and the hoax they
believed and spread this is where it
gets so absurd listen closely to this
under federal law yeah the law the
Attorney General
was not required at all zero to release
any portion of the molar report he
didn't have to release one word but in
an effort to be transparent he did it
anyway he didn't have to the AG released
the report in full only afterward acting
that which was legally required
including grand jury information
investigate vestigators sources of
methods prior to the full release
we know Barr submitted March 24th of
public letter outlining the reports key
findings no collusion no determination
on obstruction but the Attorney General
the Deputy Attorney General the office
of legal counsel all concurred pretty
much within an hour that there's no
obstruction ba or offered Muller the
chance to review his letter before he
sent it Muller declined speak now or
forever hold your peace Muller later
admitted bars summary was in no way
inaccurate or misleading despite him
writing a whiny letter about how he's
misinterpreted by the media mob me and
Muller have something in common we see
the media mob for who they are and bar
testified before the Senate Judiciary
Committee but refused to be interrogated
in the house not by the Congress men and
women that are accountable and elected
the office but by Nadler lawyers and
staff this has never happened in the 206
years of history of that committee and
Bart wasn't gonna let it happen now and
he's still willing to testify before
actual committee members I think they're
afraid of him
during this entire process Bart told the
truth he committed no crimes he went
above and beyond what the law requires
in terms of transparency now laughably
because of what I just outlined for all
of you and described a long list the
prominent Democrats they're still
calling for Bart to resign or be
impeached including crazy Uncle Joe
Biden Elizabeth Warren the Cowardly
Schiff and of course there's always
Maxine Waters no one else is calling for
impeachment she is citing level little
evidence
speaker Pelosi even claims Barr
committed the crime of lying to Congress
no he didn't and Nadler is moving to
hold barring contempt the Congress and
his con
League yes Chicken Little himself
Congressman Steve Cohen he actually he's
calling for bar to be locked up this is
their lost it their unhinged look do you
actually actually support the idea of I
mean putting him in are you talking
about just having him sit for a hearing
or locking him up somehow if you have to
have him sit for a hearing and I think
you have to have him locked up and cut
unless he agrees to participate and it
come to the hearing but do you actually
believe that the attorney that you're
going to that your committee is going to
order the Attorney General the United
States to be arrested by the sergeant of
arms and put in jail I don't know what
we'll do but we can't just go to the
Justice Department it's meaningless
they've lost their mind Democratic
congressman wants that handcuff at this
the Attorney General of the United
States have the sergeant of arms drag
him before the committee or to prison no
trial no charges nothing well welcome to
Saddam Hussein's USA now keep in mind as
we have predicting now been predicting
for years the democratic mobs real goal
has been and continues to be the
impeachment of the president they won't
let the truth or facts in any way get in
their narrative and conspiracy theories
on collusion collusion collusion take a
look to top Democrats what they said
over the weekend they've lost it look
are you concerned that impeachment talk
may actually help the president's
reelection
I'm concerned that if we don't impeach
this president he will get reelected if
we don't impeach him he will say he has
been vindicated you have said that you
think that the House Judiciary Committee
should open impeachment proceedings
I think they should begin the process I
do think they should begin the process
okay at least congressman Al Green I
gotta give him credit
an honest Democrat he's being honest
about this it's all about politics they
want to impeach President Trump he said
it why they can't beat Trump in 2020 and
they know it it's the only way to get
rid of him now congressional Democrats
are calling for mola to testify of
course another desperate attempt to keep
the collusion hoax conspiracy theories
going for as long as possible it's milk
it dry it doesn't even matter what
Muller would say at this point it
doesn't matter in the least what he says
now maybe Muller would love to take yet
another parting shot at Trump in the
administration get another dig in but he
still gets invited if he does so the
good DC establishment parties
it doesn't matter one iota legally his
report is what his report is the
decision by bars made it's done it's
finished all noise that's why the
president rightly said why are we
letting Muller testify he works for Barr
by the way the endless smearing of an
innocent man the duly elected president
of the United States this now gets
serious this has to stop now if you
don't like President Trump and you're
suffering from this psychotic rage
against them my advice to you is go try
and beat him at the ballot box and by
the way good luck with that crazy Uncle
Joe good luck but if Muller does testify
okay he should definitely be forced to
answers significant questions about his
two-year 30 million-dollar political
persecution why did he think it was okay
to hire a team of biased Democratic
donors with major conflicts of interest
question one to investigate the Trump
campaign why did he even hire Hillary
Clinton's former lawyer that's pretty
ballsy and also why did he hire Andrew
Weissman his pit bull who literally at
Hillary Clinton's victory party he was
trying to celebrate but it didn't happen
why did he hire zero Republicans why did
Muller
when did Muller know that the Trump
Russia collusion was a real hoax there
was no evidence
it didn't happen and did he conceal that
fact from the president to set up a
perjury track of why didn't he tell us
why didn't he tell the country and by
the way that would be in perjury trap on
obstruction and by the way of mullahs
mandate was broad enough to investigate
taxi cabs loan applications fare
violations tax violations why would it
not have been broad enough to
investigate Hillary Clinton's bought and
paid for dirty Russian dossier again
created by a foreign intelligence
officer spy we know now full of Russian
lies and even the New York Times
admitting that Hillary's dirty Russian
da say could have actually been official
Russian disinformation campaign chaos
creation from the very start
well what about spying did Muller ever
bother to investigate the fact that
members of the Trump campaign were spied
on how many instances were they spied on
how many spies were involved thanks to
our year plus two years of reporting in
a new story from the New York Times
thanks for catching up guys you're a
little slow on the uptake but I know you
were pushing lies for two years we know
that the Trump campaign advises George
papadopolis he was spied on by an
informant named Stefan Halper and a bond
bombshell we now Lord learned undercover
agent sent by our own government who was
flirting with them and using her charms
and suggestions of information well
we're gonna have a great relationship
that actually happened right out of a
Bond movie and on Friday the New York
Times reporter who broke the story had
this pretty stunning admission let's
take a look was she an FBI agent I'm
just what I'm gonna I'm just gonna leave
it right now as a government
investigator okay use that I used that
I'll use that wording for a reason and
I'm gonna leave it at that okay George
papadopolis said everything the story
was true except that person being an FBI
employee was it was the CIA spying
against one of our own citizens how many
spies ultimately were utilized to spy on
the Trump campaign who ordered the
spying on the Trump
and what an obama/biden knowing whether
they know it the top Intel officials try
and abuse their power bypass American
laws did they outsource illegal spying
on We the People US citizens did they
outsource that which they knew was a
illegal - friendly countries to do the
job they would not be able to do well
the Attorney General is now definitively
investigating this spying and probably
sooner than later we're going to have
the answers we deserve even sooner we'll
have the results of the Inspector
General Horowitz investigation into FISA
abuse and let's not forget John Hoover's
investigation into all the leaks
speaking of which more unearthed text
never ends the endless stream of new
information from the former FBI love
birds page instruct suggesting that
America's top Intel agencies were
rampantly
leaking sensitive information about the
Russia investigation just aft the
President Trump was elected in December
2016 struck writing page quote think our
sisters other Intel agencies have begun
leaking like Mad scorned and worried and
political they're kicking into overdrive
in an email in April struck also wrote
quote I'm beginning to think the agency
got info a lot earlier than we thought
and hasn't shared it completely with us
might explain all these weird seemingly
incorrect leads all these media folks
have well also highlight agency is the
source of some of the leaks now there
are concerns that these leaks were
coming from either the National Security
Agency or the CIA all under Obama
Biden's watch those agencies were led by
clapper and Brennan two of the biggest
Trump haters in America what did they
leak what did they know when did they
leak it when do they know it Republican
lawmakers they are rightfully calling
for a new investigation into all these
leaks surrounding the Russia probe
that's only a small portion of what we
will be getting night after night on
this program we told you we're not
stopping we're going to continue to
demand truth justice because the rule of
law the application equal application of
our laws and frankly with no hyperbole
archons
the Republic is at stake here and we do
have some really good news to report the
media is trying really hard to ignore
the economy in this country is booming
like we have not seen in over 50 to 60
years
1.3 million more job openings in America
and we actually have jobless individuals
think of that financial optimism is an
18-year high unemployment is that a 49
year low in Pennsylvania Uncle Joe's
home state guess what they're so
desperate for workers that they're
actually having job seminars in prison
what are you getting out we need to hire
you no kidding
we're seeing record low unemployment for
those with a high school degree even
those who dropped out of high school
record low levels of unemployment for
women African Americans Hispanic
Americans Asian Americans youth
unemployment on Friday in order to
explain the Trump's great economic boom
and recovery that we never got in eight
years of Obama Biden well you have MSNBC
jr. conspiracy theorists Chris Hayes he
actually took to Twitter to issue
brand-new multi-part conspiracy theories
this time about how businesses and
Republicans conspired they were so out
to get Obama that they all conspired
intentionally to make the economy bad
under Obama's presidency and now they're
working hard to make the economy good
maybe that's to do with the tax cuts the
deregulation the better business
conditions the limited government low
taxes philosophy that work for John F
Kennedy Ronald Reagan and is now working
for Donald Trump and thankfully
Americans are tuning out these
conspiracy theorists on NBC News look at
this Gallup poll Wow
president now has from Gallup the
highest approval numbers of his
presidency see how did that happen a few
points up from President Obama during
his third year in office